On January 1st, 2019, Jair Bolsonaro, one
of the most controversial politicians in international
news, became the president of Brazil.
Bolsonaro came to power with a promise: to
change Brazil, the fifth largest country in
the world, a giant that has more than 200
million people, from top to bottom in an attempt
to turn it into a political and economic power.
However folks, Bolsonaro’s first 100 days
into his term we can find headlines like these:
Jair Bolsonaro, Brazil’s apprentice president.
Unless he stops provoking and learns to govern,
his tenure could be short.
The Economist)
The Christian Coalition That Helped Elect
Bolsonaro Has Started to Crumble.
FP)
Bolsanaro’s Popularity Sinks After a Rocky
100 Days in Brazil.
New York Times)
Since becoming president, Bolsonaro has continued
with his incendiary and controversial campaign
speech, remains very active in social networks
and there’s no day in which he doesn’t
attack other parties and politicians.
Which is strange considering he himself has
been in politics 30 years and has three children
who are also politicians.
“My God, what have I done to deserve this?
Nothing but trouble!"
Jair Bolsonaro.)
Now, how can you use controversy to govern
a country?
How can you secure power without seeking pacts
or political support?
And the most important question of all: What
exactly can we expect from Jair Bolsonaro?
Listen up.
October 28th, 2018, was a historic day for
Brazil.
In the second round, after a very heated campaign
that caught global attention and in which,
the current president was even stabbed, Jair
Bolsonaro finally won majority support from
Brazilian voters.
Specifically 55.13% of the votes.
His victory, dethroned the Workers' Party
– Lula da Silva’s party – a party that
had completely dominated Brazilian politics
for 16 years.
Bolsonaro is a character known for his harsh
speech, for his support of the military dictatorship
and for his controversial comments – in
many cases of a homophobic, sexist and even
racist nature.
He promised to end the extensive corruption
that has been ravaging Brazil: to fight relentlessly
against the violence that has turned Brazil
into one of the most dangerous countries in
the world; 50 to 65 thousand people are murdered
there every year.
And, of course, to dismantle the gigantic
political framework that is currently crippling
Brazil’s society and economy.
It was precisely his economic promises that
generated the most excitement during his campaign,
causing many Liberals to side with Bolsonaro.
In turn Bolsonaro delegated the economic section
to a group of Chicago Boys led by the Minister
of Economy, Paulo Guedes.
And it makes sense to overhaul the economy
because Brazil can’t keep running like it
has been.
But hold on just a moment, Although Bolsonaro
won the presidential elections, he doesn’t
have a legislative majority.
His party only got 55 of the 513 seats that
make up the Chamber of Deputies.
And this is important, because if you don’t
have the majority in the legislature, and
you don’t seek political support from other
elected parties, how are you going to get
any laws approved?
Brazil’s Congress and Senate are very fragmented,
which is why previous Brazilian presidents
have traditionally ruled by forming pacts
with other groups.
This is known as "Coalition Presidentialism."
However, Bolsonaro simply doesn’t work that
way.
Of course...
This isn’t the new Brazilian president’s
only handicap.
Listen up.
(EASY TO SAY, HARD TO DO?)
Brazil is chaotic, it’s by far one of the
most bureaucratic and complicated countries
in the world...
And it’s that way for everyone: ordinary
people, companies, and even for politicians.
Do you want an example of what bureaucracy
means in Brazil?
Well, check this out.
It is estimated that a medium-sized company,
even a small company spends about 2,000 hours
a year declaring taxes in Brazil.
That has to be a world record.
This may help explain why Brazil scores lower
than even Argentina in the economic freedom
index and is considered to be one of the seven
countries in the world where taxes are most
cumbersome to pay, according to the World
Bank's Doing Business index.
Check this out:
And, on top of that, taxes aren’t even low,
in fact, quite the opposite.
In short, it’s a crazy system.
The point is that it feels like Bolsonaro’s
lack of experience is taking its toll.
It may be surprising to hear Bolsonaro described
as inexperienced when he’s been in politics
for more than 30 years, and almost all that
time as a federal deputy.
However, this time was served in what Brazilian
politics calls ‘low clergy’.
That is, politicians with minimal power.
Characters who are in politics but who have
neither the ability to influence nor take
part in actual decision-making.
Well, the fact is that since he was appointed
president, Bolsonaro hasn’t had a clear
agenda, his first months in office have been
a sequence of meaningless fights, controversial
statements, sudden changes of opinion, etcetera,
etcetera.
Along the way, two ministers have already
been fired, all in just three months.
So apart from attacking the press, which happens
all the time, we don’t really know what
he’ll be up to from one day to the next.
And, of course, some important ideas have
been discussed, such as commemorating the
1964 coup that led to the dictatorship.
As if Brazil had no more pressing matters
than opening these debates.
But that's not all.
Bolsonaro himself, who came to power as a
champion in the fight against corruption,
has seen its shadow loom very close to him.
One of his sons, senator Flavio Bolsonaro,
received 48 “suspicious” deposits worth
$30,000 in his bank account according to reports
obtained and broadcast by the Jornal Nacional
newscast.
Among other scandals, there have been reports
of the diversion of public electoral funds
by Bolsonaro’s Social Liberal Party to “fake
candidates” in the last elections.
These accusations led to the dismissal of
the General Secretary of the Presidency Gustavo
Bebianno, who was also none other than the
coordinator of Bolsonaro's own campaign.
That’s a great start.
And it helps to explain how, in just three
months the president's approval rating among
Brazilians dropped 16 points and that the
confidence index has gone from 62% in January
to 49% in March.
Look, we're talking about the worst record
of a Brazilian president at the beginning
of his term since 1990.
But, folks, that’s just the start of his
problems.
(MY ENEMY’S ENEMY IS MY FRIEND)
An election campaign is always different from
governing a country.
For example, in a campaign you can promise
gold and myrrh and create alliances between
parties and politicians whose only affinity
is their rejection of a different political
option.
That’s exactly what happened in Brazil.
Bolsonaro managed to bring together all the
different groups that were fed up with the
Workers' Party’s policies.
However, there’s one problem: once you reach
power and have to govern, that’s when the
differences begin to show.
This is what seems to be happening in Brazil
right now.
You see, the support system that led Bolsonaro
to the Palácio da Alvorada - the Brazilian
White House – includes a bit of everything:
anti-Marxists, evangelists, liberals, traditionalists,
military, conservatives....
And of course, sometimes the differences matter.
In a nutshell, we could say that there are
two main currents within Bolsonaro’s government:
pragmatists and ideologists.
Among the the pragmatists, who are those groups
willing to negotiate with other political
forces, are the military and the liberals.
For example, the liberal group, led by the
powerful Economy Minister, Pablo Guedes, defended
much more aggressive reforms during the campaign
than those it defends now that they’re in
power, and that’s because they need support
to get those reforms through.
A very clear example is the pension reform.
During the campaign Pablo Guedes defended
reforming the entire system, using the Chilean
model as an example.
In short, promoting a capitalization model.
Now, however, he’s promoting significant
reforms but they are nowhere near as ambitious:
A minimum retirement age, a capped pension
and eligibility based on a required number
of years in the workforce.
The government will still save a lot of money,
but basically the system structure will remain
the same.
And of course, in order to approve even a
moderate pension system reform, they need
three fifths of the congressmen and senators
to vote in favor.
So... it’s time to negotiate.
The second current that runs through Bolsonaro’s
government, is the ideological one.
And this group includes the President's own
children.
As I mentioned, the entire family is involved
in politics.
“I’ve never seen anything like it.
I don’t remember any other government in
which the family had so much power as this
one.
Family is always a problem.
The president needs to keep some distance
from his family and friends.”
Fernando Henrique Cardoso, former president
of Brazil)
The fact is that the ideologists are the least
willing to negotiate or seek consensus.
It’s piloted by this man, Olavo de Carvalho,
Bolsonaro’s Steve Bannon.
He’s a self-taught writer and philosopher
who lives in the United States and is quite
extreme.
He’s part of what is known as the Alt-right,
and well, his approaches are a cocktail loaded
with anti-communism, anti-globalism, anti-cultural
Marxism, anti-LGBT and a lot of conservatism.
This character has even criticised the pragmatic
leaders in Bolsonaro's government.
Olavo de Carvalho qualifies Mourão (vice
president) as an idiot and says the government
is running badly.)
Yes, that's right, there are already clashes
between the groups that make up the government.
And... if that’s within the government,
you can imagine how hard it’ll be to find
agreement with the rest of the parliamentary
forces.
In fact, in just three months the government
has already been defeated several times in
Congress.
But, folks, we still need to talk about Bolsonaro’s
third handicap.
(THE ECONOMY DOESN’T WORK)
We should state that this isn’t Bolsonaro’s
fault as it stems fundamentally from the disaster
caused by the previous government, the Workers'
Party, which led Brazil into one of its worst
crises in 2016.
But even if it’s not their fault, Bolsonaro’s
government is going to have to deal with it
and work with an economy that’s not performing.
Basically, the country has a huge public deficit
of between 7 and 8% per year.
Public debt keeps growing and is already at
around 80% - which is a lot for a country
like Brazil.
To make matters worse, there are 13 million
unemployed and the economy is struggling.
(Citi cuts 2019 Brazil GDP growth forecast
to 1.8 percent.
Reuters)
Faced with this situation, Brazil almost doesn’t
need a Minister of Economy, they need Doctor
House.
Obviously such a big deficit doesn’t give
the government much margin for anything and
if you have such huge imbalances and no growth,
things will only get harder.
There’s only one solution: budget cuts.
And that’s precisely what the government
wants to do with pensions, which is by far
the largest expenditure for the Brazilian
government.
More than 40% of the government's budget goes
to pensions… and some estimates even suggest
that in the next decade this rise to above
60%.
This is not surprising because Brazil has
one of the most generous systems in the world.
The country’s average retirement age is
54 years and the average pension is equivalent
to 70% of the final salary.
That means, you can retire at 54 and for the
rest of your life you get 70% of the salary
you were earning just before you retired.
Obviously, this is not sustainable.
"Brazil has one of the most generous systems
in the world.
If there is no pension reform, ... Brazil
will head towards insolvency and a debt crisis."
Chris Garman, managing director of Eurasia
Group, a political risk advisory firm.)
The problem?
Cuts are never popular…
And folks, if Bolsonaro really wants to change
Brazil for good, he’s going to have to negotiate,
and that means a lot of compromise.
The question is, can he do it?
Leave your answer in the comments and in this
survey.
Anyway, as you can see, these are the factors
that have overshadowed Bolsonaro’s first
months as President of Brazil.
If he manages to build a coalition of political
support to transform the Brazilian economy,
we’ll be glad to tell you all about it.
And if he doesn’t, his government may not
last very long.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.